So let's talk about objections and let's talk about our plan to overcome each of these objections
I want to make one important note before we hop over the screen and that is you only need
to create this once I am going to give you a cheat sheet but I'm going to I'm going
to ask you or I'm going to invite you to make some tweaks and do things you know the way
that it makes sense to you so if there's a way that I overcome an objection that just
doesn't feel right doesn't sound right doesn't really vibe with you feel free to change it
the cool part is just like the keyword list you only have to build this once and then it's just
a matter of slowly refining this process okay and what I mean by this process is these objections
and the way that we're gonna overcome them okay so let's hop over to the cheat sheet guys welcome
to FFM 2.0 objections cheat sheet so what I've got here is I've listed out the most common
objections and then I've listed out the way that I overcome each of these objections which again
I want to invite you guys you're free to make some slight tweaks to the ones that don't really
make sense don't jam with you don't vibe with you don't whatever with you don't sit well with you
that's fine this is just what I do okay so I'm gonna go through these really quick the most
common objections are these are the following okay number one I need to talk to my partner and
this aren't in order by the way this is just the list I need to talk to my partner number two I
want to do a commission or paperly deal basically the deal structure right number three you know
price this is too expensive number four is trust and trust they're not gonna come out say I don't
trust you it's gonna be like hey can I talk to some customers can I see your website can I look
at some reviews can this one is hard because they're not gonna come out and say hey I don't
trust you okay most people won't say that or they're gonna say how do I know it's gonna work
right five I want to think about it and six I don't do contracts okay so let me talk about really
quick we're gonna go into all these number one I need to talk to my spouse slash partner how do
I overcome this preemptively offensively and I've listed here really simply when setting up zoom
call make sure all decision makers can make that time and stress on the value of both of your time
so I just let them know I'm like hey is it just you that owns the business like you could be a
little tactful here hey it's just you do you have a partner okay cool make sure they're on the call
tomorrow because I don't want to play telephone and have you having to talk to them and the whole
thing so make sure if you have a partner they're on tomorrow that's it very simple because that's
the only way to overcome it is make sure that all decision makers are present on that call okay or
if they say yeah that person you know my partner is out of the country or whatever say oh okay so
just to confirm just to respect both of our time if we talk tomorrow and we can work something out
you're not gonna be one of those guys like I gotta go talk to my partner right like you can make a
decision because if not let's push the call a little bit okay just be candid with them say that
up front okay number two I want to you know I'm just saying the objection I want to do a
commission or paper lead deal you're gonna have a lot of people that say hey I don't want to do a
flat fee deal or you know I'd like to just do a commission where I just add a little extra and I
pay you a percentage or I'll pay you ten percent Nick I'll pay you ten percent on what I close
right tons of people are gonna say this and we're gonna overcome this very simply during the pre
closed screencast and we're gonna be talking about that very soon in the next couple lessons I
explained that with commission there's no skin in the game and I explained that it's not profitable
for either party to do commission or paper lead and I have a story for each of those and we're
gonna get into that but basically in the pre-closed screencast I let them know that it is not a good
use of anyone's time and I give examples okay and it never comes up by the way I never have people
asking they're never hey can you do this or hey can you this because there's a couple reasons why
that's number one the other reason and the other way that I overcome this is if you send people
good quality leads in the setup during the Costco sample strategy phase they're not gonna be as
worried the reason people want to do commission or paper lead is because they're worried they're
not gonna get leads or that the leads are gonna suck okay so part of it is actually getting them
next objection that you might get or you will get at some point is it's too expensive they're
not gonna come out probably and say it's too expensive because they're too prideful but they're
gonna say hey I just can't justify that blah blah blah blah so the way I over I overcome this is I
again I give them quality leads during the Costco sample stage just like I told you in the commission
slash paper lead how to overcome that but I properly during the pre-closed screencast and even
sometimes on the close I make sure to show them the lead value calculator and show them just how
valuable these leads are worth and one of the biggest things that I've heard over and over and
over from students that have gone through this program already is that they didn't know what
their leads were worth they didn't value their leads enough and when you value your leads and
you have a lead value calculator to show them hey look at how much this is worth if you get even
12 leads with these concrete leads you're gonna make this much money okay and when you show them
this and this isn't a lie and you don't want to oversell but when you do this properly their mind
is blown I never ever ever get this objection because I explain how valuable these leads are
during the pre-closed screencast during showing the lead value calculator and by the quality of
the leads that I send during the Costco sample strategy which is also part of the setup okay
number four is trust this is again this is a really difficult it's like a touch-and-go a feel one this
one's harder they're not gonna come and say I don't trust you okay they're typically gonna say hey do
you have any reviews do you have any case studies do you have any people I can talk to can I see
your website how long have you guys been in bit like all these things mean they don't trust you
okay and so here's what I do is and I put again same as above with the samples okay which is the
leads that we send this is why sending these leads up front and good quality leads is so freaking
valuable because it overcomes so many objections the biggest one we talked about this during the
the biggest one that actually overcomes is the objection of trust and that's why because it's
so hard to overcome and I also noted here also during the pre-closed screencast show ample case
studies and social proof and for those of you that are like I don't have any cases I don't have any
samples or I don't have any social proof great leverage other people in the group and their
projects until you have your own no no issue with that and I will let you leverage mine if you'd
like as well number five I want to think about it okay here's how I do it I always let them know
the morning of or the night before I just let them know as I call them and say hey are we good for
XYZ time okay cool and this is me talking like you're the business owner okay cool sounds good
the reason I ask I have a let's say the calls at two by the way I say the reason I ask I have a
call at four with another company and I'll even make sure that that company is someone I've talked
to you I have a call at four or I have a call later this afternoon I just want to make sure
it's not gonna conflict I plan on canceling that as long as and assuming we can work something out
but I just want to make sure there's no conflict okay and what you're doing there is you're
planning that seed like okay first of all this guy this lady she has options he has options okay
number one number two is when they go I'm gonna get back to you on Monday I'm gonna get back to
you on Friday it's like no I told you I have a call later this afternoon and I told you I only
work exclusively with one company so you can wait until you know next year for all I care but if I
find somebody that's ready to rock and roll I'm working with them so shit or get off the pop man
we doing this or not okay last one I don't do contracts which I think is so ironic and I love
I don't say I don't do this because I preemptively want to teach you guys to bring this up but when
I used to post emptily and I when they taught me to wait for the you know the objection I used
to love burning them when they would say I don't do contracts I'm like oh that's interesting I'm
like that that phone you have in your hand um I guess and you just paid cash for that right it's
like what thousand bucks like no well no I'm on like a plan oh okay okay interesting well that's
a that's a contract that's a two-year contract and then they'd say or I'd say hey well this
house did you pay cash no no I guess it's like no listen man listen lady you do contracts you
got a cell phone you got a house you got a car you do contracts that's part of life okay all right
like it was like very aggressive but anyway just a quick side note here's how I preemptively
overcome it okay during the zoom close I remind them that since this is exclusive I'm gonna need
a commitment or you're you're gonna need a commitment from them just like you're making to
them okay and you want to frame it as a good thing as a protection against the price going up but
listen think about it this way you are being married to them essentially you're being married
to them you don't have the ability to go and look for other companies right because you are
married to them you are exclusive with them so how does it make sense that I'm exclusive to you
I'm committed to you I can't talk to any other companies or send them any other leads but you
get a walk away whenever that's like being married to someone and they can go do whatever the hell
they want but you are stuck and you can't do anything okay doesn't make any sense okay so for
me to be exclusive to you I need you to give me give me a fair shake and we got to do this for six
months the other reason and I'll say this as well is we're gonna have just to be candid we're gonna
have some slow months we're gonna have some really hot months and we're gonna take the average of
these six months and this is going to be a net net profitable win-win but I don't want you after
one month we have a slow month because of the weather because of this or because it takes a
while to get warm this year and you all of a sudden just think this sucks I want you to give
this a fair shake so we can see what it's like during some of the slower months and some of the
warmer months because I want to work together for 10 years I'm not looking at this for you know a
couple months so we've got to do a six month deal to start and then after that we can go from there
okay so guys these are the objections these are the objections you're going to get and these are
the ways that I preemptively these are the ways I personally preemptively overcome them one last
thing I want to note is any objection that you keep getting over and over and over just use this
same exact model meaning just bring it up first bring it up first I got to give some love to some
people in our group that actually taught me this and pointed out that we can just do this for any
objection and so one of the students that's in this group they mentioned that they kept getting
the same objection over and over which was they would get on the call and the business owner kept
saying well I haven't closed any you know leads I haven't closed any of these yet okay and I don't
ever get that so I know it's probably something in the way that they were doing the hook or
something that they were saying however they kept getting it and so this individual she realized
I'm just going to bring this up first so immediately when they hopped on the call
she would say hey so I know you got those leads and by the way just so you know I understand like
you probably haven't even closed any that's pretty typical I mean I only sent you a couple the purpose
wasn't to have you close a deal the purpose was to send you a couple to try them out and if you
close one great but we understand like it's a numbers game right just something very very
simple like that instead of waiting for the customer to say hey I didn't close any I'm not
doing this she went after it she went after the objection never an objection again so if you guys
have any objections keep getting over and over and over guess what well put it on your cheat sheet
and bring it up some at some point whether it's during the phone call when your life transfer
leads whether it's during the pre-closed screencast or whether it's right at the beginning
of the close bring up the objection first and it will become a non-objection